[Music]  it's a huge part of her past and a huge  part of her sensory memory that's why we  go back to those memories so many times  and I feel like isn't that how it is for  everybody  you know you hear a song and it  instantly takes you back to a certain  place in your life  keep singing maybe it'll come back to me  and so that's part of what brings her  back to herself and so part of that  ownership and way that she's rooted back  into herself as is with that heart  t-shirt it's also like I did like my own  little detail to it it's the only time  her in that shirt it's the only time  that she's not standing with with fists  her hands are relaxed oh my god  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  that just happened  we rock Yahoo rock  [Music]  [Music]